late at night guys and I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry night Jerry at night and Ryan
at night we just came back from watching
Star Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace
brilliant film really beautifully done
mm way better than the original yeah so
this is gonna be a spoiler free review
yeah no spoiler spoiler free zone we
don't want to ruin anything especially
cuz the trailer so barely told us
anything as well but we're gonna do a
spoiler review it's gonna be a podcast
we don't know how long it's gonna be but
there are so many spoilers to talk about
and ours and our podcasts get ready for
it guys but let's hop right into this
let's do John boyega John boyega he's
the reason I wanted to see he's the
reason I wanna see it too because they
cast a black actor as the lead and I'm
very happy very happy about that
somebody gonna be like not a big deal
anymore people like me yeah
representing my people John boyega he's
great man I was very happy with with the
way he played this role and I mean you
know I'm just psyched for him cuz like
attacked blocks [ __ ] awesome I didn't
realize he would be in America or have
an American accent this movie and a
place Finn and Finn is this character
with a lot of personality there's
something I really admired about the
writing it was character because I mean
you see the trailer it's like you didn't
he didn't watch any of the trailer so
you got very lucky saw no trailers but
when you watch the trailer their
advertising him like he's gonna be this
really serious epic performance they
just use all his breathing shots I fell
that one pictures I saw the picture
floating on Facebook like right after he
stands up in the troop reference yeah
whatever they use all the shots of him
sweating and breathing heavily yeah but
he has a lot of personality of the
character humor a lot of humor he's
really funny had some really funny
moments in this toy and he's very
natural with those you know I was happy
to see you know cuz like I think
attacked the block was like his first
movie and then this yeah he brings a lot
of personalities very natural you know I
wasn't expecting them to do some of the
things they did with his character and I
really liked what they did I like the
kind of character isn't what his I like
the history of his character too he's
actually the most relatable it's like
they took
Rey and Finn don't want to give it away
but they they're kind of like some parts
of Luke Skywalker in both of them you
know we and they're things that he does
where you're like man that's not like
the heroic decision necessarily but I
get like I get why this character is
behaving this way and that carries over
into everybody like I think the best
thing this movie has going for it is his
personality absolutely this movie is fun
it's a movie it's it's got heart it's
got everything that we love about the
original Star Wars in my opinion they
immerse you in this world like you and I
didn't even realize it till I got out of
the theater like whoa I was just in the
Star Wars world I got lost in it and I
didn't even realize that I did because
it was done in such a good way or its
kind of seamless the way they do it it's
more than just observing an
awesome-looking picture yeah I love how
the story came before the visuals so
much there are some amazing visuals
don't get me wrong but the story and
characters really did come first you
know that's what I'm remembering the
most as I'm sitting here is the scenes
between characters people talking about
stuff people figuring things out it's
kind of neat that those are the most
memorable things to me are character
moments yeah and I gotta say when they
brought back like the characters that we
knew would come back they brought them
back in the right timing yeah the right
fashion and what I loved
they let the characters age yeah you
know like Han Solo is in the film but
he's not Harrison Ford trying to be Han
Solo he's on solo at this age yeah what
he's not anything with the other
characters yeah it's like when we meet
Han you're like yeah that is probably
realistically what he would be doing if
this yeah and there's like none of them
pick up like oh this is exactly how they
were when we left off it makes sense
it's been so many years they're much
older now and you see that these guys
have changed and been through other
experiences along the way that we didn't
get to see when you get the sense of the
thirty-year you know time difference
between the last you know between
Episode six and and Episode seven stuff
has happened it was happily ever after
it was like oh you know the universe is
continuing to push forward and there are
threats and you know people are building
armies and stuff you know and Harrison
Ford is great it felt more Harrison 40
than Han Solo he
but a very garlis it's like well I don't
sell those pretty much Harrison Ford so
yeah he's happy he's really charming
Harrison Ford and that was the thing is
when he showed up I was like you know
cuz Harrison Ford seems like the kind of
guy who will occasionally do stuff for
you know for the check
he's pretty overt about that and so I
was like oh good like it seems like you
really do want to be here I just love
and that they made him a full character
it wasn't like cool cameo from Harris
yeah look we put him in the video oh no
he's a part of the story
I like how they made his character grow
from just the starting point but you
there's a point and there's a lot more
experience in Han Solo yeah and before
you know and there's a there's more
sympathy to he's not just like I don't
give a [ __ ] about anyone yeah like he
has an attitude every now and again but
you could tell he's a lot more caring
this time around yeah he's he's Han Solo
thirty years after you know the events
we saw before and he's not there for fan
service he's there because he served the
storms a part of the plot Daisy Ridley
as Rey
she did a great job too I mean yeah
she's pretty but she's got the intensity
as well at times you're like well you
live in [ __ ] desert world and you
still look like beautiful all the time
but that's something we can easily move
past with Star Wars you know yeah really
distract me I don't want to sleep well
and also it's not like you know the
cameras ever googling her whatever yeah
how is she looks she looks a little
dirty she looks like she's dressed for a
place that's windy and gross but also
hot Leia I know and it's just like it
she just kind of looks like part of that
world it helps in these movies too
because there are so many different
kinds of people and species and aliens
and stuff around that the variety helps
make up for that too I gotta say though
when it comes to her performance I
thought she gave this to facial
expressions way too often which was
either like there's some variation of
that like eyes wide tense up verge of
tears hey you know and regardless of
that one little thing I said about Daisy
really she she does a great job and I
love her character I was actually I was
worried about the first couple scenes
she was in but once she was on screen
for more than a few months and her story
actually stood to kick in
I actually I quite liked her
a character that I think can fall into
being either OneNote or having two
expressions it for me I didn't feel that
one her and John boyega I thought were
great
you know centerpieces for this movie and
their characters I want a third great
character yeah they're great characters
to continue the Star Wars story with cuz
at first I was watching it I was like
then I found myself forgetting about
that yeah and just really enjoy these
characters journey not having seen the
trailer I didn't know if they told us
anything about what their roles in the
story would be you know when certain
people showed up I was like oh cool like
I didn't realize that's what you would
be doing now you know like with Princess
Leia and stuff like that and I remember
on the teaser trailer there was a debate
where people like is that r2d2 and then
was like no it's not what was it bb-8
BBA bb-8 the do you know the droid that
circles with me that way yeah the the or
Bueller with the little pod on tile I
liked him I thought they gave the droid
a lot more personality it's like he's
like r2d2 but more flexible a little
more spry a little more quick yeah and
he can like move his head and [ __ ] poe
dameron play by Oscar Isaac he did a
great job - yeah man I didn't even
realize it was Oscar either did I this
guy and then and then a few minutes in I
was like wait
Oscar Isaac isn't that is that's Oscar
Isaac like he can disappear with just a
simple change of his haircut and beard
like he can disappear into roles
he's a cool character that I hope is I
wanted more in the sequel I feel like
some people might feel like they didn't
use enough of him I felt like he was
used just right for this particular
story but I do want to see more of him
in the sequel I mean I would have liked
to see more but I almost it's weird for
this movie for me I almost feel like not
getting enough of certain things is a
good thing the actors did a good enough
job in there and they're well enough
written I want to see more of these
people and I assume we will you know
especially of the newer cast people kylo
Ren he was a cool villain kylo is very
cool and he wasn't a two-dimensional
villain always not invade like you said
he's not Vader he is a different guy
with serious temperature yeah like you
get the sense that this guy is like
powerful but
kind of struggling to hold it together
hey he's conflicted and he's traumatized
he's confused then yeah you know you see
he's what anakin skywalker should have
been so one two and three they do some
interesting things of that character
they keep him from just being like yeah
the dog because at first it comes across
like that's always gonna be yeah you
know he sounds like being a little bit i
love his voice possible i know
everyone's freaking out about his like
lightsaber with the actual like no but
advantage in the actual choreography
which i thought was cool cuz i'm like oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] hurt you decide we yeah
and give you more options a porter is
for you lightsabers the action sequences
however i like the action sequences a
lot but at the same time there were a
few of them where i was like a this
seems like you could have been a little
cooler specifically the fight sequences
were they're mainly just blasting with
guns at each other yeah I thought all
the flight sequences were great they've
been like the lightsaber fight I when it
came to the just the blast blast up I
was like yeah like there are a few
fights that I was like those are really
cool but a lot of them it almost feel
like the movie was like okay we gotta
have a fight but let's get back to the
story like yeah you know because some of
the action sequences you feel the
emotional gravity on a few of them
however I don't really feel the
intensity behind most of them when
you're watching it I'm not like oh my
god these characters are in danger I
don't like that always felt like
everything was gonna be all right that's
the only sort of complaint I have about
this movies like I was never you know
and maybe this is just in contrast with
all the other action movies we get now
but I was never like oh my god like how
are they gonna get this one some of the
stakes with the actual you know fight
stuff was we're a little low for me like
oh my god like I was always more
invested in the character scenes JJ
Abrams Star Trek movies like the action
scenes are like whoa I can't craziness
and these actions these are not that way
yeah yeah and I almost appreciate that I
appreciate that cuz it feels like it's
really continuing Star Wars yeah like
it's an actual movie
this movie seems like it's concerned
with its plot enough to like put in
action scenes but keep the plot going
and they have a plot that's exhilarating
enough it's not like the prequels where
it's like we're gonna watch another
Senate hearing now even the character
stuff is on you know a time limit and
they gotta move yeah no JJ Abrams knows
how to bring that fast paced this to it
but yeah what I really want to mention
every JJ Abrams movie you feel JJ Abrams
behind the camera yeah this one it's
like he just wanted to tell a Star Wars
story there were certain shots from like
that's a JJ Abrams shot most of the time
though I yeah whenever they do like I
love it yeah when he kept them he put
them in very sparingly he said that
thing about like I didn't really like
Star Trek that much and I just maybe
like you could tell he kind of went
hog-wild on Star Trek or Star Wars you
can feel the referee you know he's like
I really want to treat this right and I
can't go into this right now because
it's gonna be spoilers but especially in
the finale I felt like some stuff was
really like some a lot of stuff I felt
like was good ol Maj then other times I
was like that's been done before kudos
to all the practical effects in this you
know there was a lot of sense or CGI of
course but it was a decent blend like
it's a decent one yeah it's like I was
really psyched to see a lot of the
animatronics and a lot of the you know
puppets and stuff and a lot of the
practical makeups there's some really
good CG and there's also some times
where you're like that's a CG creature
yeah this is an actual movie with flaws
and I almost appreciate it more for that
I feel like a human made this movie and
I'm happy I feel like a fan made the
movie which is awesome hey you know like
a filmmaker who happens to be a true fan
of Star Wars this movie overall gave us
what we wanted which was great homage
and honoring the original same time
giving us fresh things a few surprises
here and there and spacing the surprises
out really nicely and couldn't like just
really continuing this story telling a
new trilogy that seems likely to happen
in the Star Wars universe it's not like
we really don't [ __ ] do this you know
and it gives you a lot to look forward
to because there are people who appear
in this movie who you get the sense will
appear much more in later movies
yeah you know talking about it I love
this movie yeah I think it's great it
feels genuine and I appreciate that
well guys can't understand a review
without a rating system right Oh still 5
out of 5 jus bakas jus baka the other
Jewish 2 pockets anyway guys if you knew
the channel subscribe today become a
reject reasons to Jerry de éstos hosted
by Jerry on this channel spoiler review
coming out hopefully by Sunday it's
gonna be a podcast so keep your ears up
yeah and thumbnail time